اخبار عمليه طوفان الاقصى من معبر رفح على
الحدود مع مصر اهلا بكم ارتفاع عدد
الشهداء الفلسطينيين الى
2750 وعدد المصابين الى نحو 100 الا
وتحذيرات من كارثه بيئيه مع وجود جثامين
اكثر من الف شهيد تحت الانقاض في حين قالت
سلطات القطاع ان المواطنين يشربون مياها
غير صالحه
للشرب تواصل الغارات الاسرائيليه الكثفه
على
والقسام تقول انها قصفت اسدود وتل ابيب
ردا على استهداف المدنيين وعلى الحدود
الشماليه اشتباكه متقطعه مع حزب الله
والجيش الاسرائيلي يعلن تعزيز قواته ويقول
انه سيرد بكل حزم على اي
عمليه بايدن يقول ان احتلال اسرائيل لغزه
سيكون خطا ولكن دخولها للقضاء على حماس
ضروري ووزير خارجيته يعود الى اسرائيل
لاجراء مباحثات بعد جولته بعدد من الدول
العربيه في حين قال الاتحاد الاوروبي ان
المعاناه الانسانيه لا يمكن ان تكون ورقه
مساومه ودعا لمنح الامم المتحده حق الوصول
الى غزه دون
عوائق مقتل طفل فلسطيني في السادسه من
عمره ب 26 طعنا في ولايه الينوي الامريكيه
كما اصيبت والدته في حادث اعتبر جريمه
كراهيه حرب غزه بايدن وصف عمليه القتل
بالوحشيه وشدد على رفض الاسلاموفوبيا الى
اللقاء